reasontv was on the campus of the
University of New Hampshire for last
night's democratic presidential debate
before and during the televised desktop
between Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton we caught up with supporters of
both would be nominees who held dueling
rallies outside the debate hall why are
you supporting Bernie why not i stands
for everyone are you an American citizen
I'm American Jason I'm okay yeah I'm
that Donald Trump over here I just want
to make sure you were eligible to vote
for your supporting Bernie I am you
seemed a little hesitant fair you're in
it you're in a Bernie crowd it's not a
real big secret voting on the topic of
climate change and morning why I'm
supporting Bernie like one of the big
reasons why a lot of college students
support him is because of his ideas of
lowering tuition rates are even getting
rid of them completely would you support
Hillary if she's the nominee or would
you go third party I would do I wouldn't
I wouldn't do / party I 08 I'm a
Democrat now I believe that if Bernie
doesn't win he will do though I will
support Hillary it's if she wins which
she won't would you support Hillary if
she was the nominee or would you go
third party yeah Hillary's the nominee I
yeah I will support the best my people
can do and will support Hillary but
we're gonna keep on pushing after that
are you supporting Bernie Sanders no I
am NOT supporting the democratic party
for their foreign policy and as being
the parties i represent capital as an
actual socialist I don't think bernie is
a progressive nor socialist I think you
look at Hillary's plans in there things
that will get through Congress she's
known for working across the hours you
look at Bernie and he has great policy
but I don't think it'll get passed so to
prognathism is what's attractive a
l'heure exactly I um she has my full
support just because I'm a female I
think a woman should be in power and
I think she does a great job up there if
Bernie were the nominee would you
support Bernie I would support Bernie I
think he's amazing as well so how do you
think Bernie's doing so far I think he's
doing it very well I think he's giving
some low blows to Hillary and I think
he's holding his own I think he's doing
well I think that Hillary's being rather
slanderous especially towards the
beginning but I think he's holding his
own nicely what notes has Bernie hit
tonight that speak to you that speak to
me um I mean he's mostly doing the same
speech that he does because he's true to
what he believes in unlike Hillary
Hillary's all over the place and she's
flip-flopped a lot and she's denying
that which is also lying so I don't
think that that's very consistent either
would you support Hillary if she were
the Democratic nominee yes